[Música]
Qué tan grande fue ese pz que capturaste
así de grande así de grande así de
grande Sin evidencia fotográfica no hay
prueba de que capturaste algo gigantesco
y esa es la verdad desde los albores de
la pesca de hecho cientos de años atrás
mucho antes de que la fotografía llegara
para capturar el momento Los Pescadores
japoneses inventaron su propia forma de
registrar Las capturas de trofeos La
llamaron gyotaku el giot taku es el arte
antiguo de estampar peces que se originó
en Japón como una forma de registrar Las
capturas de trofeos antes de la cámara
moderna de hoy en día guo significa pez
y taku significa estampar existen
muchísimas historias acerca del origen
de giot taku pero básicamente comenzó
porque Los Pescadores necesitaban
documentar de alguna forma las especies
y el tamaño de los peces que capturaban
desde hace más de 100 años Los
Pescadores llevaban papel tinta y
cepillos consigo al mar contaban
historias de grandes Aventuras en el mar
Como algunos japoneses reverenciaba
algunos tipos de peces Los Pescadores
sacaban el estampado de estos peces y
luego los devolvían al mar para hacer el
estampado se pintaba al pez con tinta no
tóxica sumie y se estampa sobre papel de
arroz de esta forma se podía devolver al
mar o limpiarse y venderse en el mercado
estampados iniciales como estos se
hacían solo para registro y carecían de
detalles adicionales no fue Sino hasta
mediados de 1800 que se comenzó a pintar
los ojos y otros detalles en la
impresión un noble famoso lord sakai era
un pescador ávido y cuando pescó algo
grande quiso tener un recuerdo del Gran
besugo del mar rojo para ello le encargó
a un pescador que estampar su captura
después de esto muchos Pescadores le
llevaban sus estampados de giot taku a
lord sakai quien si le gustaba su
trabajo los contrataba para que le
hicieran sus estampados muchos
estampados colgaban en el Palacio
durante el periodo edo después de este
periodo el giot taku ya no fue tan
popular y comenzó a aparecer hoy en día
el giot taku se ha vuelto una forma
Popular de arte que muchos disfrutan y
se dice que los estampados le dan suerte
a Los Pescadores pero esta forma de arte
es muy diferente de lo que solía ser hoy
en día la mayoría de los artistas
aprenden por su cuenta mediante ensayo y
error antes que el artista comience a
estampar se necesita preparar al pez
para el estampado primero el artista
coloca el pez sobre una superficie
ahuecada luego el artista extiende las
aletas y las clava sobre la superficie
para secarlas luego el pez se limpia con
agua para realizar el estampado Existen
dos métodos diferentes el método
indirecto comienza adhiriendo una pieza
de tela o papel humedecido sobre el Pez
usando pasta de arroz luego el artista
utiliza un tompo o una bola de algodón
cubierta con seda para aplicar la tinta
sobre la tela o papel y realizar el
estampado este método requiere de más
destreza y se debe tener mucho cuidado
cuando se retira el papel del pez para
que esta no se desgarre en el método
directo el artista pinta directamente
sobre el Pez y luego presiona la tela o
papel humedecido suavemente sobre el Pez
con ambos métodos ninguna impresión sale
exactamente igual pero con ambos se
logran imágenes impresionantes del pez
para el toque final el artista utiliza
una marca o sello para firmar su obra y
así mostrarla y decir el p será
exactamente así de grande quieres seguir
Aprendiendo suscríbete a nuestro canal
mantente conectado y
curioso